we're going to make sure ukraine has the
weapons to defend themselves and from
invading russian force
but look
the idea
the idea that we're going to send in
offensive equipment and have planes and
tanks and trains going in with american
pilots and american crews
just understand and don't kid yourself
no matter what you all say
that's called world war
iii
okay
let's get it straight here guys
that old expression don't kid a kidder
president biden promising to make sure
ukraine has weapons to defend itself but
not fighter jets reports are that biden
personally killed a plan for poland to
give mig-29s to ukraine while his own vp
is now calling russia's vicious attacks
on civilians war crimes gop senators are
furious and demanding biden start
putting pressure on putin
i believe there's a sentiment that we're
fearful about what putin might do
and what he might consider as an
escalation
it's time for him to be fearful of what
we might do we might as well call the
commanding general at fort lewis outside
seattle and tell him to go take down the
flag and surrender our position because
we will never stand up to russia if
every time vladimir putin says boo we
back
down okay so let's start with the with
the mix-up all right that that poland
refuses to give the migs directly to
ukraine and they want to send them to
germany so that we can give them to
ukraine lincoln says we will and then
now the reports are that biden said no
we're not going to if we're going to
make sure ukraine has weapons to defend
itself
why not megs
illogical and weak judge let's deal with
illogical first why is it and i don't
understand the red lines completely here
but why is it not crossing a red line to
send man pads or surface-to-air missiles
or javelins but somehow to offer up migs
is beyond the pale that would provoke
vladimir putin i don't understand that
logic especially when it's described to
me as look they wouldn't be that
effective anyway in helping the
ukrainians if they're not that effective
why would it provoke vladimir putin but
now to weakness i do agree with mitt
romney and tom cotton i think there is a
very very thin needle here that must be
thread i do respect the potential as we
all should of nuclear escalation
but
there's something
more than something to be said for the
way that president trump handled his
business with unpredictability leaving
your enemy wondering how you might react
it's clear this administration projects
predictability irrationality and
weakness
if we do this we're worried you may do
that giving vladimir putin every
opportunity to do whatever falls outside
of those lines we need to be more
unpredictable stronger and more rational
all right uh jesse if u.s backs off
every time it signals i i agree with
that and now it's become partisan
because you have 40 u.s senators
republicans calling for these migs and
that's not how it should be we should be
united on this and putin sees that he
sees nato split he sees political splits
here and that wasn't good we shouldn't
have had this conversation out in the
open like that we were fine with the
poles transferring the jets
that was fine we just didn't want to
bring them off our air base in germany
and the germans didn't want it coming
off the german air base that was an
escalation in our opinion and that's
because we hadn't been giving them jets
to begin with we've already been loading
them up with javelins and javelins cost
eighty thousand dollars an old mig these
are like 4.5 million so in our
estimation that was a huge escalation so
the question is if you give them the
migs
and russia escalates we have to then
escalate then you're on the escalator
that's the concern from the west because
right now we're safe
things are fine this is a one-on-one we
don't need to make it a five-on-one
it's like when your buddy's buddy gets
into a fight it's not your buddy but
he's your buddy's buddy so if your buddy
jumps in then you have to jump in and
that's what we're trying to avoid
somebody excuse me you jump in with me
if somebody was fighting me you're my
buddy okay so dave but not your buddy
i'm staying out of it until you jump in
so degen if every time the u.s backs off
whenever putin says well that is
engaging in war this is engaging in war
doesn't putin then just continue to do
what he's been doing for the past 20
years he's committed war crimes before
in chechnya and in syria i mean we're
just giving him he's the schoolyard
bully and nobody says anything
well he's certainly shown so far that
nato has no teeth
uh number one number two to to to will's
point why was all of this information
being played out about the migs in
public
so to all of the
moronical
uh liberal trump haters and the
trump in republicans who said we finally
have an adult in charge
and this is what we get we get
afghanistan and this where they can't
settle the only the world should have
found out that potentially jets wound up
from
poland in ukraine when some russians got
killed
with them that's how the world should
have found out that we would have lost
world war ii if this is how strategy was
conducted with a megaphone over the
radio
well the polls jammed us up a little too
yeah which by the way shows a weakness
in biden's ability to keep nato together
if some random eu diplomat can throw a
mig transfer under the bus what else is
he not in control of right but you know
the amazing part of this is the one
thing that we're not hearing a lot about
harold is the fact that there seems to
be some communications going on in
turkey
uh behind the scenes with uh
sergey lavrov who's being personally
sanctioned but he's over there
negotiating what do you think's going on
there
i think potentially a lot i think jesse
framed this exactly the right way
we can dislike and disagree with the
president but i think they've done a
pretty darn good job with a medium-sized
hand how they've dealt how they played
the hand out
if you what jesse said comes to fruition
the president believes and military
advisers believe you could escalate to
some place we don't want to be
now you got to balance that with i don't
always agree with the cotton guy i agree
more with romney on this than i than i
do romney laid it out well saying we
have to if he's escalating how come we
can't match the escalation i think it's
a legitimate question on the part of
everyday americans who wonder with this
incredible military our incredible
strength and our abilities how come
we're allowing this guy to to move us
around and our president says look we
got to keep middle together he's not
moving us around as much as you think we
are we're winning more than we think
furthermore uh we got to we got to
balance this out now i'ma believe we got
to give them every other weapon we
possibly can i'm still a believer we
ought to try to find some fighter jets
there's some democrats who agree with
those 40 republicans who believe we got
we ought to advance jets there but we
should not ignore the reality that if we
do
and if they escalate and we escalate
again when does the escalation uh turn
into a tactical light nuclear weapon
being used does it depend upon who's
flying the jet
well not and so the idea behind is if
you give them the jets they're going to
fight and they're going to they're going
to use the jets themselves however
who knows they'll it might who knows i
mean i think that's that's the question
and i i wish there's not a great neat
answer to this unfortunately hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else